ammettiamolo ammettiamolo l'uso salto
subito al tema ma non posso mettere nel
far i convenevoli che poi ci stiamo due
anni e non finisco più il video vengono
viene una cosa di 7 minuti che nessuno
si incula ormai al potere ci stanno
solamente loro so che alcuni di voi non
sanno di cosa stai parlando
ma sono altrettanto convinto che alcuni
di voi hanno già capito tutto quanto sì
perché in questo paese quello che
bisogna fare stagionare stagionare
stagionare come tipo il formaggio il
vino e il vino mi sa che non si scagiona
il vino si invecchia no vi spiego perché
il sogno di molti miei amici è quello di
diventare immortali e quindi
automaticamente penso che sia il sogno
della maggior parte delle persone così
in rapporto poi vedi certi film e
capisci perché loro vogliono tutto ciò
edward m pettinatura i perché sei nudo
scusami e che avevo i capelli lunghi e
non mi piglia vado a farmi
l'acconciatura comunque sai come più ami
spogliano e più acido che mi guarda le
tombeau lisma mi uccide e adesso potremo
bombare come non mai giusto si sono cose
che non ti ho detto del tutto dei miei
noi vampiri siamo morti
ok edward questo l'avevo capito e non ci
batte il cuore
ecco non scorre nemmeno il sangue nelle
vene tanto di guadagnato lo hanno capito
tutti che sono un'umana necrofila da
casabella continui a non capire il
sangue non scorre da nessuna parte e non
gonfia nulla merda
ammetto di aver usato questa battuto ed
averla riadattata solamente per arrivare
al punto per punto della questione al
nocciolo che e molto probabilmente anche
noi rimarremo fregati come i due tipi di
prima dall'immortalità perché perché
qualora noi volessimo diventare
immortali dovremmo sperare di diventarlo
dopo gli 80 anni e portandoci per
l'eterno
cose tipo reumatismi borse calvizie
occhiaie e rughe alzheimer
arteriosclerosi perché perché perché
dovremmo fare tutto questo
ve lo spiego subito gli anziani sono
ovunque sono molti più dei giovani e se
avete un vicino molto probabilmente avrà
pure una certa solo un anziano può dirti
la frase sono un anziano se è un
maleducato fanno un sacco di energia
nascosta e capitolo primo ma non ne
avete mai visti come per strada con i
loro bastoni menano fendenti alle
macchine che non ti danno precedenza
sulle strisce hanno un sacco di energie
nascoste capitolo 2
alcuni di loro li vedi correre come
pazzi nei party alle 6 di mattina bene
frullati rimango come madonna hanno uno
strass accodi energie nascoste il remake
alcuni di loro conducono le ditte di
vere e proprie rockstar e sesso droga e
gli scribi nile
anche se il motivo della droga
spiegherebbe perché hanno tutte queste
energie che poi scusate se faccio un
attimo discorso serio ma cosa serve sei
giovani oggettivamente se la giovinezza
viene risucchiata da dei dinosauri
schifosi che sono attaccati ai loro
posti come dei vostri e che ti
permettono di prendere i loro posti o
comunque di vivere anche te nel mondo
quando anche tu stai morendo come loro o
che poi io so già che la mia coscienza
mi direbbe vogliamo scusami se ti
interrompo ti ricordi l'amica dito
cugina vuoi forse mettere lei nel mondo
a fare le scelte importanti ma chi sono
gandhi e dostoevskij scusa sono
evidentemente se non la senti di radio
non cantano bene come justin bieber
no non dico quello va beh allora
parliamone compagni di classe tuo
fratello tipo quando io mi taglio le
idee
io sento una filovia
vabbè ma uno così è da sbattere in
manicomio va bene allora ti prende
qualcuno di più mature nazionale e lo
farà mai
totti roma che mi prendi il rom né
costretto che c'è tra la ragazza che ha
incontrato una settimana fa nell'autobus
salomoni amore amore non ci credo ciao
giacomo dice questo dimessa uomo di ok
che sai che ti dico mi ha convinto se
essere giovani vuol dire dover dire
comodino invece di cioè non me lo dire
allora sì sì
preferisco essere una mummia decrepita
compagna di classe di ramsete ii e
personal trainer di mosè anzi sapete che
faccio adesso mi vado ad attaccare dello
scotch strategico per favorire la
comparsa delle rughe
naturalmente da questo quadro di
disperazione escludi minonni che sono
belli buoni spendenti ciao
una sarta nera sotto stanza c'è che alla
fine tutto un po spento
se io mi sento spento con la sofferenza
io sento tipo un effluvio